hello my name's stephen nunn and i'm the
new
deputy leader of malden district council
i'm sure i don't need to tell you that
this
covid19 pandemic has had a marked effect
on all of our lives
on yours and your families it's also
impacted on our local shops and
businesses
particularly in modern high street
as a result morton district council
wants to do something to help you
and to help those businesses and in
consultation
with the local shops we've decided to
offer some free parking
the dates that have been fixed and i i
have them here on this piece of paper
are every thursday from 2 o'clock
onwards
starting on thursday the 3rd of december
and going through to thursday the 14th
of january
we hope that you'll find this gesture of
benefit
and support we also hope that it means
that you'll shop locally
that will help our businesses and it
will help you hopefully to have
a very merry christmas whilst you're
doing that of course we must continue to
follow the rules in terms of face masks
hand washing and distance please do that
please have a really merry christmas and
let's hope that we look forward to a
much happier
new year